if brave and cars2 taught us anything is
that Pixar is mortal so now we return to
the world of Monsters Inc a beloved
franchising that's it's not a bad move
monsters University
so monsters University is a prequel to
monsters Inc in which Mike Wazowski and
Sullivan they're young now and they're
in college and they're learning to be
scary monsters so they can scare
children so children will scream so they
can power their world the monsters Inc
is one of my favorite Pixar movies I
love that movie back in the day and then
you watch it now like over a decade
later and you're like still good it just
holds up on so many levels
so it's monsters University as good as
Monsters Inc no it's hard to be on the
same level as a class that we granted
Toy Story 3 did it but is it good yeah
it has its familiar formula which is a
good formula for a movie like this but
it's really safe it's the internship
with monsters it really is what it is
these guys are in college through the
underdogs they need to work together to
triumph you know so they go through this
decathlon of challenges to prove that
they're the best
however the internship wasn't the first
movie to do it monsters University will
not be the last movies use that formula
because the formula does actually work I
did like how Mike Wazowski and Sullivan
they did play off each other really well
Mike's the book where I mean oh he's
like all right I gotta study my books
and be the best scary monster I can be
Sullivan's a legacy child his parents
were a big deal so his name carries
weight it was like I don't need to try
I'm Sullivan I like how the movie showed
that only carries you so far but it also
shows that you need more than book
smarts to excel in the world book smarts
will get you the a-plus is in class yeah
when you carry it out to the world you
need more than that you need experience
you need this other thing the world does
operate like that I like the fact that
this movies like nah we're not going to
be s you hear this this is how it works
so we're also these cool throw backs of
Monsters Inc some of them were really
shoehorned in the movie or like alright
you wrote that in there just to have
some little quirky one-line tie-in
sometimes that starts to irritate me I'm
like you could have done it in a more
clever way than just someone saying
something but you can't help but go oh
yeah I know what they're talking about I
know they're talking about because I
like monsters Inc what anything about
this movie is the movie looks like it
wraps up or like okay this is the end of
the movie that's fine then you realize
it has another half an hour to go you're
like whoa don't push it now I don't want
to
like out of this movie feeling like it
was a half an hour too long or anything
but if I'm gonna be honest with you the
last half hour this movie is my favorite
part of the movie if the previous hour
and a half of this movie felt like the
last half hour this movie this movie
would be superb I'm serious about that
the first hour and a half is enjoyable
yeah but the last half hour felt more
like what I liked about monsters ain't
cool to know that that feeling is in the
movie it still has good comedic timing
more than comedic timing I'd say it has
clever moments it's not like I was
laughing out loud like I was dying and
laughing in the movie there are a lot of
times I was like I was pretty clever
so monsters University was really
enjoyable I had fun with it it's gonna
appeal more to kids and adults for sure
you still walked out going that was a
lot of fun it was a really good movie
I'm gonna go a little higher than you
might have thought I was gonna go but I
will say I would buy monsters University
on blu-ray
I feel like Pixar's getting their stride
back you walk out of monsters University
going okay you guys still get it where's
the monsters University have you seen it
what did you think of it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more